esta fábrica produce autopartes en
Buenos Aires actualmente funciona a
pleno rendimiento las exportaciones del
sector aumentaron un 11,6% en 2022 sin
embargo temen que esto se revierta
después del acuerdo entre mercosur y la
Unión Europea el sector Automotriz
podría ser el más afectado por el
acuerdo ya que la industria en Europa es
más competitiva y moderna y sus
vehículos no tendrían aranceles así lo
explican desde la asociación de fábricas
argentinas de componentes que
representan a más de 200 empresas para
un sector con más de 55.000 personas
empleadas que no hay inversión implica
que luego la producción de ciertos
productos ya no se haga o de cierto
productos de nueva con nuevas
tecnologías se decida que no se hacen
acá se hacen en Europa eso implica que
va a haber menos demanda de mano de obra
en Uruguay el país vecino desde hace más
de 50 años Lancer
uniformes para empresas de todo el mundo
mercosur fue muy importante para el
textil uruguayo sobre todo durante
periodos de estabilidad ahora Uruguay
estudia un tratado de libre comercio con
china al margen de mercosur la cámara de
la vestimenta de Uruguay teme que el
sector pueda desaparecer con ese acuerdo
por la diferencia competitiva
pantalones a una camisa algunas cosas
que todavía se siguen fabricando en
Uruguay y donde todavía somos un poco
competitivos así como estamos
Este Ahora sí de golpe desaparecen los
recargos y eso sería ya el punto final
de la Industria
a sus 32 años mercosur espera ratificar
en Julia el acuerdo con la Unión Europea
mientras discuten con Uruguay un acuerdo
con china en conjunto o uno separado que
podría resquebrajar La Unión